Now that we understand abduction, and now that we know the diagnosis is
an instance of abduction, let us ask ourselves, how does this understanding help
us in choosing hypotheses? So the first principle for choosing a hypothesis is
explanatory coverage. A hypotheses must cover as much of the data as possible.
Here's an example, hypotheses H3 explain data items D1 through D8.
Hypothesis H7 explains data item D5 to D9.
Assuming that all of these data elements are equally important or
equally salient, we may prefer H3 over H7 because it explains for
of the data than does H7. The second principle for
choosing between competing hypotheses is called the principle of Parsimony.
All things being equal, we want to pick the simplest explanation for the data.
So consider the following scenario. H2 explains data elements D1 to D3.
H4 explains data elements D1 through D8. H6 explains data
elements D4 to D6 and H8 explains data elements D7 to D9.
Now if you went by the criteria of explanatory coverage, then we might pick H2,
plus H6, plus H8, because the three of them combined, explain more than just H4.
However, the criteria of Parsimony would suggest if you pick H4,
because H4 alone, explains almost all the data, and
we don't need the other three hypothesis. In general this is a balancing act
between these two principles. We want to both maximize the coverage, and
maximize the parsimony. Based on this particular example, we may go with H4 and
H8. The two together explain all the data and in addition,
the set of these two hypotheses is smaller than these set of hypotheses H2,
H6, and H8. The [UNKNOWN] criteria for choosing between competing hypotheses is
that we want to pick those hypotheses in which we have more confidence.
Some hypotheses are more likely than others. You may have more confidence in
some hypotheses than in others. As an example, in this particular scenario,
H3 may explain data items D1 to D8 and H5 may explain more data
elements from D1 to D9. So H5 also explains D9 that H3 doesn't.
However, we may have more confidence in H3, and so we may pick H3 instead of H5.
Once again this is a balancing act between these three criteria for
choosing between competing diagnostic hypotheses. A quick point to note here,
these three criteria are useful for choosing between competing hypotheses even
if the task is not diagnosis. The same problem occurs for
example in intelligence analysis. Imagine that you have some data that needs to
be explained and your competing hypothesis for explaining that particular data,
well, you may pick between the competing hypothesis based on this criteria.
All of the task is not a diagnostic task. These three criteria are useful for
explanation. Diagnosis simply happens to be an example of this [UNKNOWN] task.